LittleBigPlanet 3 is out at the end of
November and last week I had the
opportunity to check out the beta now
I've always been a fan of the series
when I first bought a PlayStation 3
it was the LittleBigPlanet bundle that
caught my eye and I've always enjoyed
completing the games campaigns
in saying that like what I can only
imagine is the vast majority of people
playing it
I suck at making levels I usually give
it a go for the first couple of hours
and then disappear into the user
creations for the rest of my time so
this time around I gave myself a
challenge to learn how to use the tools
and create mode and to try and build my
own level headed it go
you'll see welcome to create mode what
is it that fills your brain space
desperate to burst forth and be given
form okay so first things first the main
barrier to entry with any LBP is using
the tools like any level design tool
there are a lot of moving parts and LBP
3 adds even more of them extra
characters a whole bunch more depth and
dozens of new ways to interact with the
levels however unlike previous games in
the series which required me to use
trial and error to teach myself LBP 3
has a new area called the puppet puzzles
which act as a single-player tutorial
for learning the creation tools each
lesson concentrates on a new concept
like say editing size or replacing
objects or adding behaviors and you're
expected to use what you've learned to
speedrun a section at the end of each
level these puppet puzzles actually do a
great job of making using each of these
systems second nature and I really hope
that they add a bunch more of these to
the final game so after playing a bunch
of them I give myself a few hours at the
side to see what I can come up with what
did I come up with well some sort of
golf course thing with a bunch of
spectators and a monkey on a mountain
the thing that I really enjoyed what
creating levels in LBV 3 was playing
with the new depth the logic systems in
the game are clearly the main driver for
most popular levels but I just enjoyed
getting comfortable with what the puppet
puzzles have taught me up until that
point after a while I needed inspiration
so I delve into the user-created games
and realized that people had already
made stuff that is so far beyond my
means
it hurts my brain utilizing new
characters and deeper levels to create
everything from endless runners to Zelda
clones this is similar to the loop I've
always had with LVP I try and make
something get frustrated then go to the
user-created levels for inspiration and
basically get disheartened however this
time it wasn't the tools that became my
buyer to entry I found him easier to use
than previous games so I went back and
chipped away some more and played around
with interactivity I've still not made a
level I feel comfortable sharing but for
the first time with a little big planet
I felt my design was under my control I
kind of knew what I was doing so if I'm
gonna take one thing away from my time
with the beta it's that I hope sumo
digital add more of those Popat puzzles
maybe ones of higher levels cuz I gladly
keep learning and maybe over time I'll
create my LDP
magnum opus for now though it's clear to
see that the wider community is capable
of making enough crazy levels and
hopefully with these new tools and
tutorials more of us than ever before
we'll be able to also time will tell
LittleBigPlanet 3 hits the PlayStation 3
and PlayStation 4 on November 18th here
in the US 26th in Europe and 28th in the
United Kingdom and Ireland this is a
blank canvas ready to be molded into a
wonder that all the Imagi sphere can
enjoy